good evening we continue to follow
breaking news here at five o'clock a
suspicious item found at the trump hotel
here in las vegas thanks for joining us
i'm denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
joe moeller has been tracking this he is
now joining us live from the scene joe
metro says after reports of a potential
bomb being inside of the trump
international hotel crews were called
out here to investigate and determine
that there actually was no hazardous
material but this investigation is just
wrapping up here's a live look outside
the trump hotel the south end just north
of the mall there you can see that
there's one metro unit
still here crews just opened that road
once again just after one this afternoon
metro responded to reports of a
suspicious bag inside the trump hotel
they say a man came inside and dropped
off that bag in the lobby and told
people that there was a bomb inside that
suspect then left the hotel employees
there also got calls of a bomb threat
authorities responded and after
investigating determined no hazardous
materials were there that suspect was
later found
our team did an incredible job i think
this community can be very proud of our
police officers within a very very short
time frame they were able to track down
locate and apprehend the suspect that's
involved in this so he's currently in
custody
crews were still searching the area for
any possible suspicious packages or
materials after as well many hotel
guests were waiting outside of the trump
international hotel trying to get any
sort of information about when they can
get back in now back out here live
you're taking another look at
just north north side of the mall on
sammy davis junior there you can see
people are now being let back in the
mall that entrance was closed for some
time and they just let a guest back into
the trump international hotel many
people are reaching out wondering when
they can get back in so that is open and
people can't get back in there but this
investigation is all wrapped up here
that suspect is now in custody reporting
live outside the trump hotel